avec le blanchemaison vous êtes donc
toujours avec nous encore un vaccin pour
les russes celui pour les animaux donc
les russes ont eu manifestement le
paquet sur la recherche contre le coc
vite c'est important pour un grand
nombre de pays d'être en pointe de
l'innovation
oui bien sûr les autorités russes le
gouvernement russes ont mis comme vous
le comme vous l'avez dit le paquet est
liée à élire un an et que tous les
abords at war se sont mobilisés pour
rechercher les éléments de vaccins anti
corticoïdes et on connaît la valeur des
des scientifiques russes et notamment
dans ce domaine par conséquent après le
spoutnik v qui que dans monsieur poutine
a parlé pour la première fois au début
du mois d'août de l'année dernière
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est un vaccin pour
les animaux qui donc est annoncée qui a
été homologué aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs par les autorités compétentes
en russie alors ça n'est plus un sujet
pour l'organisation mondiale de la santé
est un sujet pour une autre organisation
internationale qui s'appelle
l'organisation internationale pour la
santé des animaux
c'est très important parce que les
épidémies chez les animaux peuvent avoir
une incidence d'abord sur l'alimentation
on l'a vu avec la grippe aviaire dans le
passé et puis sur la transmission
éventuellement à l'homme sur ce sujet
actuellement l'om est-ce dit qu'il n'y a
pas de preuve qu'il puisse y avoir une
transmission directe à l'homme mais dans
le fond on n'en sait rien et donc ce
nouveau vaccin va être produit en russie
il a été testé et il semblait pour
efficace à 100%
d'après ce qui a été publié aujourd'hui
et naturellement il pourra être utilisé
sur les animaux domestiques les chats
les chiens est en effet à quelques cas
dans plusieurs pays y compris en russie
qui ont été déclarés et puis sur les
visons on vient de citer le danemark et
des pays-bas où les élevages entier
devises ont dû être détruits parce que
il avait le govic 19 et d'autres animaux
comme les renards notamment qui peuvent
contaminer qui peuvent contaminer
d'autres d'autres animaux eux-mêmes
alors justement toques blanches maison
dans ce contexte de pandémie la
discussion hier soir entre emmanuel
macron viala merkel et vladimir poutine
alors du jour les vaccins notamment
pourquoi cette réunion était
indispensable pour asseoir les
différents je crois que c'est très
important parce que comme vous le savez
en fin de semaine il ya eu un conseil
européen en vidéoconférence et au début
de ce conseil européen le président
monsieur charles michel a fait état
d'une conversation d'une heure et demie
qu'il venait d'avoir avec vladimir
poutine et au cours de cette
conversation delà des murs poutine avait
dit mais dans le fond il faut reprendre
langue avec l'union européenne
il faut que nous arrivions à trouver un
ordre du jour deux sujets positive de
sujets sur lesquels on peut coopérer
ensemble et parmi ces sujets il a
évidemment inhumé ray le réchauffement
climatique bien sûr mais aussi la
coopération dans le domaine sanitaire
alors au conseil européen
la question n'a pas été plus loin
puisque le le sujet a été renvoyé à une
session ultérieure
mais il est logique que la chancelière
allemande le président français et le
président russe reprenne ce point comme
d'autres d'ailleurs parce qu'il sait pas
le seul point qu'ils ont tous évoqué
dans l'eure dans leurs conversations
hier mais c'est logique qu'ils
reprennent ce point et qu'ils évoquent
en effet la possibilité d'utiliser le
vaccin scouts nick v dès que l'autorité
européenne des médicaments
laurent homologué sans doute dans
quelques semaines puisqu'une une mission
doit se rendre en russie pour examiner
pour voir les laboratoires qui
fabriquent ce vaccin est donc il ya
encore un certain nombre de 2,2 d'examen
à faire pour que ce vaccin soit validée
il pourra ensuite être mis sur le marché
et un certain nombre de pays
européens ont d'ores et déjà indiqué
qu'il utiliserait la même l'a utilisée
déjà en utilisant son autorité purement
national de validation
c'est la hongrie mais je pense que
d'autres pays vont se déclarer
en tout cas tous les pays du sud de
l'europe l'ont déjà fait l'allemagne l'a
déjà fait et puis un certain nombre de
pays ont également déclaré qu'ils
étaient prêts à fabriquer ce produit
donc ils sont en négociation de nature
commerciale avec le fonds
d'investissement qui possède
l'entreprise qui fabrique ce vaccin en
russie pour pouvoir le fabriquer et pour
déterminer les conditions de cession du
brevet et dans quelles conditions ce
vaccin pourrait être fabriqué monsieur
mac on a beaucoup insisté encore ce soir
sur le fait qu' une entité comme l'union
européenne doit avoir une maîtrise
industrielle sur la fabrication que ces
vagues de ces vaccins eh bien je pense
que d'ici quelques mois le vaccin russe
sera aussi fabriqué à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne comme il l'est déjà
en 1 2
le contrat passé par le le fonds le
fonds qui possède l'entreprise de
vaccins et bien a passé un contrat avec
plusieurs laboratoires indiens avec
l'inde est le premier fabricant de
vaccins au monde et il a commandé 600
millions de vaccins 600 millions de
doses dont une grande partie est
destinée aux pays aux pays du
tiers-monde
merci claude manche maison expert en
relations internationales et dante